CHASE HANSEL: Hi.
I'm Chase.
I'm a product manager
for Google News
and Google One Pass.
Today I will be describing One
Pass, and then Omi , the tech
lead for One Pass, will be
explaining how to implement
the product.
What is One Pass?
One Pass is an easy
to use, API for
authentication and payments.
It's a complement to Google
check out for provisioning
access to content from
Google accounts.
And it's an authentication
platform for user rights.
Here's an example of a website
using One Pass.
And the basic scheme is that
you can go to a website.
We can check if someone has
access to a piece of content.
User doesn't have access, so
they see an option to pay.
They then go and pay
using check out.
And afterwards, that Google
account has access to the
content, and so they see
the full version.
We'll give a couple examples
of One Pass in the wild.
So this is a German website,
Tomorrow Focus, which is the
example I just showed.
But here's my basic scheme,
where I showed up, I don't
have access to content.
Note the Google page is in
English, because my browser
setting is for English, so this
is the default translated
for all the markets
that we're in.
I'm just going to sign in using
my personal account.
I have bought this content about
18 times at this point.
Wrong password.
OK.
So we just did a check saying
that I didn't have access to
the content, and now it's
asking me to purchase
this for EUR 0.10.
So I purchase the content.
And now I'm back on the page.
And I have access.
So if I then refresh this page,
came back, it wouldn't
prompt me for check out,
I just have access.
So here's another example,
a US website
called Courier News.
It's a small publication
in Missouri.
So this is actually implementing
something called
metered access.
So as you're going to see,
I'll be able to get a few
articles before I'm
prompted to pay.
So there's one for free.
Someone's obituary.
Two for free.
Three.
And here's the prompt.
So this prompt is asking
if you want to sign up.
In this case, I do.
So this is asking you if you
already own a print edition.
So I'll show you the
different options.
I said yes, and now it's giving
me an option to have a
discounted price.
If I said no, it'll
give me those.
So here I'm actually going to
buy the print one, just so I
don't charge myself more.
Because it's going to
my personal account.
And here we are.
So now I just purchased access,
and now I have access
to all the content.
And I won't ever be hassled
again unless I have to log in.
OK.
So what can One Pass be used?
It's a web API for content.
So that means it can be used on
the phone, can be used on
mobile web, can be
used in app.
It can be used for newspapers.
It could be used for
magazine content.
We have one customer who's
thinking about you doing TV
streams. It's really
kind of up to you.
This is a web API, and it's
designed to be flexible.
The business model that
One Pass supports.
So One Pass is designed to be
super easy and flexible,
handling a wide variety
of different cases.
It supports subscriptions,
as you just saw.
It supports paper article,
rentals for a period of time,
things like free trial.
So you can do a month free
trial, and then you got access
to recurred billing
for subscription.
Metered access as you saw.
Access for non digital
subscribers.
So that was one example that
you just saw with Courier
News, where they actually
integrated their print
subscribers.
There are other ways to do that
as well, but we support
it pretty readily.
And finally, discount coupons.
So in case, you have a phone
version, and you want to get a
tablet version of a magazine,
we offer that kind of
functionality.
So the cool thing about this
is that you actually set up
the technology, and then
the business model
is agnostic to that.
So all the business model
for configuration is
done using a UI.
This is a UI that's coming
out, I think, this week.
And basically, this allows
you to set up things like
subscriptions, paper article,
you name it, in 30 seconds.
You basically save the part of
your website or your [? L ?]
structure that you want to block
off for content, and
then configure a business
logic, and you're done.
And the changes are
made instantly.
So one of the cool things about
this is it allows you to
do dynamic pricing per day.
So say you could charge
something at $5 the first day,
and the next day, go in and
change it, and it's $3.
You name it.
It's designed to be flexible.
So One Pass is a payment
is designed to enable
transactions on third
party websites.
What that means is that
the publisher is
the merchant of record.
So we're not a marketplace.
We provide the publisher with
all the user data required to
complete a transaction for
fulfilment and marketing, if
the user chooses to continue a
relationship with the publisher.
So you would want to contrast
that with something like
Android Market or
the Apple Store.
This is the publisher
hosting content.
This is the publisher.
And this is not a
market place.
It's just enabling
transaction.
So what are our requirements?
Has to be easy.
We have to support all
common browsers,
desktop, mobile, in-app.
Minimal upright configuration
and set up.
Minimal back end requirements.
Ideally none.
There's no database.
There's no user depository.
Our goal was to have nothing
on the back end.
We ended up with one server
side call, as Omi will
describe, it's for
security reasons.
This is an extremely secure
system, and it's surprisingly
simple, given how
secure it is.
All or most integration should
be on the client.
We're talking about drop-in
Java script, and
one server side call.
With that, I'm going to
introduce Omi, the tech lead
on the project, and he'll
explain how to
implement One Pass.
OMI CHANDIRAMANI:
Thanks, Chase.
So I'm going to talk about what
it takes to integrate
with One Pass.
And we're certainly going to
look at some code and so on.
But before we dive into that,
I'm going to take a high level
look at what the user flows
are that you would need to
implement in order to integrate
with One Pass.
And this kind of breaks down
the demo that Chase showed
you, where you first access
the site, you don't have
access to the content, you go
through the flow of paying for
the content, and then finally,
there's a flow where you have
access to the content.
And we're going to break
that down and see
how all of that works.
You're going to see a lot of
boxes and nanos, but later on
you'll see that how a lot of
this boils down to just a few
lines of code on your part.
So don't be intimidated by
the number of steps.
The power of the system is that
we've abstracted a lot of
these steps behind a very
simple and clean API.
So the first flow we're going
to start with is the
interaction between the user,
your site, and One Pass, when
the user hasn't bought access
to the content yet.
So it starts with the user
accessing the content.
The first thing that happens
is that your site will
redirect the user to a One
Pass URL, are which is
checking to see if the
user has access to
the content or not.
At that point, if the user's
not logged in, they're
presented with a standard Google
log in page, where they
can enter their Google
credentials.
After they've logged in at that
point, One Pass knows who
the user is, and what they're
trying to access.
So now it has all the data
that it needs to
figure stuff out.
And what it does is it checks to
see that user has purchased
an offer which would give them
access to that content.
So in this scenario, we're
going to say that no
purchase was found.
What One Pass then does is
redirect the user back to the
original content that there
was looking at.
Except this time, we pass an
additional URL parameter.
You're going to see this
in a lot of the code.
It's just a simple access
check response.
Values are yes or no.
In this case the user doesn't
have access, so
the value is no.
And in entering that page now,
the publisher site can see
that URL parameter in the URL,
can deduce, that OK, the user
doesn't have access
to this content.
And now the publisher
knows what to do.
It needs to present the user
with a way to buy the content.
So some kind of a UI, which
presents the price.
Maybe there are different
options, you can buy monthly
or a single article purchase.
So UI to present to the user,
so that they can start the
purchase flow.
So let's take a look at what the
purchase flow looks like.
This still starts at where
we left off before.
The user is now looking at these
various offers that they
can choose from to buy access
to this content.
They pick one, and then the
publisher website will
redirect the user to a One Pass
Checkout page, passing
the ID of the offer that the
user chose, so that we know
what to charge the user for.
One Pass then takes care
of a lot of stuff.
You'll see that this redirect
is a single line code.
And a lot of things happen.
If the user hasn't used Google
Checkout before, they're put
through the sign up wizard for
setting up a Checkout account.
They can add credit cards.
If they're existing Checkout
users, they can manage their
credit cards and so on.
It's a very rich UI into
Google Checkout.
But at the same time, if this
is a logged in user with an
existing Checkout account,
credit card's already in
there, like you saw in Chase's
example, all you get is this
one page and the buy button.
And as soon as the user
clicks on buy, the
transaction is processed.
And it's pretty straight--
It's a one screen, click on
one button, you're done.
So once you click on that buy
button, completed transaction,
the user gets to redirected back
to the original article
that they were looking at.
Again, there's that access check
parameter that I was
talking about earlier.
It's added to the
URL this time.
Response equals yes.
But that's not good enough.
We add an access token to that
URL, which the publisher can
use to confirm that the user
does indeed does have access.
And I'll get into that into a
little detail in a moment.
But basically, once the
publisher has--
I'm sorry, I'm getting
ahead of myself here.
So with this access token and
the response parameter in the
URL, the user once again
tries to access
that purchased content.
Which takes us into the next
flow, which is where the
user's now paid for the
content, and is now
trying to access it.
So this looks very much
like the first flow,
user accessing content.
They get redirected back to One
Pass for an access check.
This time, when we check for a
purchase, One Pass finds one.
The user's redirected back
with the response URL
parameter and the
access token.
This is where the publisher
calls a simple API on the One
Pass side to validate
that token.
If that token is valid, you can
be assured that the user
does indeed have access to
this protected content.
And the publisher can send that
content to the browser
for the user to look at.
So let's talk briefly about
this access token.
It's kind of the cornerstone
of what makes One Pass a
secure solution.
So what is it?
It's a piece of data.
And it looks like a string.
Garbled string.
Numbers, letters, uppercase,
lower case, all that
stuff, in the URL.
And what it is is it
encapsulates the user, and the
offer that they bought
in this context.
And now, given those two bits
of information, once you try
and validate that token and
pass it back to One Pass,
given the user and the offer
that they bought, and the
article that they're trying to
access, it's a quick check to
see that the user does have
access to the content.
And once again, we respond back
to the publisher, saying,
just say yes or no.
If it's valid, we send yes.
And the publisher can rest easy
that they're not giving
access to content that
shouldn't be given.
The tokens are signed
and encrypted.
They can't be manufactured.
Nobody can make one or make
sense of one, except a One
Pass server.
Bulletproof.
So what does it take to
integrate with One Pass?
Let's get into some
of the code.
It's just a few simple steps.
The first thing you do is you
set up offers, using that
offer UI that we're releasing
this week in
the \publishers center.
You add access checking
code to your content.
And then code to respond to
where the access is denied, in
which case you show offers to
the user, and code to respond
to if access is granted.
You validate that the access is
indeed valid, and send that
content back to the user.
Pretty straightforward.
So let's start with a
piece of content.
Finally, some code.
Very simple, HTML file that
you may be hosting on your
site that now you've decided
you want to charge for.
You don't want it to
be free anymore.
So with [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
a simple example, I'm going to
be using JavaScript and jQuery
in these slides, just because
it's compact.
And a lot of people are familiar
with jQuery, but you
see that nothing I'm really
doing is complicated.
It can be done in your favorite
JavaScript library.
Or really, if you want do the
whole thing on the server
side, no magic going on here.
Very simple stuff.
Everything that's complicated,
we've hidden behind our APIs.
So let's get started.
First thing to do, let's remove
the content that you
want to now start
charging for.
And maybe you replace that with
a snippet of the original
article, something to convince
the user that they really want
to buy this.
So while we're here, I've also
started building this form.
This will be where we show the
user what offers they can buy.
There's a million ways
of doing this.
I'm just doing a very simple
form, just for
simplicity's sake.
You guys, I'm sure, will come
up with pretty clever ideas.
But for simplicity, I'm going
to use just a simple form.
The next thing we really
need to do is the
access check itself.
So you'll notice I'm escaping
the URL that the user is
currently looking at, and you'll
see why in a moment.
So remember in the flow where
the user was accessing content
for the first time, and the
publisher website at that
point doesn't know does user
have access or not.
And does it redirect to One Pass
for the access checking?
So if the URL doesn't have
that response parameter,
basically an access check
hasn't happened yet.
So we look for that parameter
in the URL.
If it doesn't exist, we redirect
the user to the One
Pass access check URL.
We pass the escaped URL as a
parameter in this redirect.
That parameter is
pretty important
for a couple of things.
Of course, this is how One
Pass knows what to check
access for.
You're trying to access
this URL.
Is this an offer you've bought
that gives you access to it?
That's straightforward.
The second reason One Pass needs
this URL is that this is
where the user will send the
user back to, after the access
check is done.
OK, so the next thing we add
here is handling the case
where the response parameter
is in the URL, but the user
doesn't have access to
this content yet.
So the show offers method, what
it does is present the
user with choices as to how
they can buy access.
So let's a look at what
that show offers
method might look like.
So here we're basically making
an API call to the One Pass
pricing API.
It returns a list of offers,
any of which will give the
user access to the content
that they're
trying to look at.
This create offers method gets
passed to JSON object, which
includes metainformation about
all the offers that
the users could buy.
And then that method
is up to you.
You present that JSON data in
whatever way you see fit.
Again, you're in control
of this UI.
So it's very easy for you
to make a very seamless
experience for the user when
they're on your site.
But by the time show offers is
done executing, we're in the
state where the user's looking
at offers to choose from.
Let take a closer look at that
JSON data that gets passed to
the create offers call.
Very straightforward.
As we mentioned before, a
single URL could match
multiple different offers.
You can play with different
ideas, where you want to see
if people will buy single
article access.
Will they purchase a single
article at a time, or will
they go for monthly
subscriptions?
In this case we've said give the
user choices to do either.
So in this case, the first junk
of JSON says, for $0.50
you get access to the single
article forever.
And the second one, is for $10
you get a monthly subscription
maybe to the whole site,
or whatever the news
section, all up to you.
Again, this is a small,
minimalist data set.
The point is that we don't
need to expose all the
metainformation that defines
the offer here.
We just need to send to the
browser just enough
information so that you can bill
that UI to present offers
to the user.
It's also entirely possible, by
the way, you just have one
URL will have just
a single offer.
Maybe you only have monthly
subscriptions.
That's cool.
That's fine.
It works.
And your offers UI that I've
been saying is just a buy
button or a link.
And it could be as
simple as that.
Doesn't need to be very
fancy at all.
This whole process is
entirely up to you.
OK, so I've just shown what the
offers UI might look like,
based on the JSON that
I showed you in
the previous slide.
In this case, each offer just
becomes a radio button for the
user to choose from.
This is very basic.
You guys will make something
much prettier, I'm sure.
But the key point about this
slide is that the user's
presented with a buy button.
When they click on the buy
button, they're sent to that
One Pass Checkout URL.
They're sent there, and
that's where the
transaction's processed.
It's a one click process
if you're an
existing Checkout user.
And then once that transaction
is complete, the One Pass then
redirects the user back to this
original URL with the
response parameter
and the token.
So this is the last step.
Let's see how we handle a
request in the case when
access should be granted.
So response will be yes, and
there's a token in there.
OK, so in this case when access
should be granted, you
notice it wasn't in
the JavaScript.
We just had a-- is there
a response parameter?
If there's one, does
it equal no?
The case when access should be
granted when the response
equals yes, that really
needs to be handled
on the server side.
Any kind of decision
making logic in
JavaScript, on the client--
you could do this
on the client.
You can see there's nothing
special here.
Any decision that's made
on the client can be
instrumented.
It takes a few seconds to write
a little JaveScript to
do whatever your JavaScript
was going to do
if access was granted.
So it's really crucial that that
decision not be made on
the client for a secure
solution.
So in my example, I'm using
a Java back end.
This is a standard
Java servlet.
Any Java developers
in the house?
Great.
You'll recognize a
lot of this code.
It's pretty boilerplate stuff.
I'm extracting URL parameters
from the request. If the
request had a URL parameter
response and it equaled yes,
and it had a token, which was
valid, I send the full article
to the client.
This is a valid request
for protected content.
And in this full article, you
wouldn't need to send all the
access checking logic and the
offers UI logic, all that has
already happened by now if the
user has reached this point.
And then the L statement
here is, if the
user didn't have access.
And this is when you'd send the
short form of the article,
or the snippet, however you're
doing it, and the code to
build the offers UI.
And I need to remember this
highlight these chunks of code
as I talk about them.
OK, so we kind of glossed over
that valid token step.
Let me show you what
that looks like.
Java developers, you're going
to see that I've copied and
pasted 90% of this, just like
I'm sure you all have done
many times before.
This is just what it takes
to read the contents
of the URL in Java.
The only bits that weren't
copied and pasted are what's
highlighted here.
The first highlighted bit
is the API to One Pass.
That would be, of course,
specific to this
implementation.
And we're passing the
token in there.
And the next interesting bit is
the last line, the return
statement where we see if the
API request to validate the
token, did that reply
with a yes or no?
Very straightforward.
No need for XML parsing, JSON.
It's a yes or no.
We just send that back.
Very straightforward.
And that's all the
code we need.
Just a couple of things
to point out.
I've shown you a lot of
inline JavaScript.
Just for brevity, all of that
JavaScript could very easily
just be put in a JavaScript
library of some kind.
Included in your standard
template,
header, footer, whatever.
And you've now got a very easy
way to add access checking to
whatever part of your side
you want on the whole
site, if you wanted.
The second more powerful point
I'm going to make is that no
where in the code, did we say,
is this a subscription?
Is this a single article
purchase?
Do we need to do something if
tax is included or not?
Is there a free trial?
There was no cool that
did any of that.
And that's the power of
One Pass, actually.
All of that is configuration
to us.
So if you change the price of
something, you price it too
high, and you realize you need
to experiment with a lower
price, that's just a
configuration change.
You want to go from a monthly
model to a biweekly model,
configuration change.
Code doesn't change at all.
We've taken care of all
of that when we
do the access checking.
So if you change the structure
of the website, again nothing
needs to change as far as this
implementation code is concerned.
I think that's pretty
powerful.
So let's just summarize
to wrap up here.
What do we have to do?
You wrote a few dozen lines of
JavaScript code on the client.
Less than that on the server
side, if you use some
JavaScript libraries.
You didn't have to have a
user management system.
You didn't have to set up
a database of any kind.
No messy integration with card
software and daemon processing
and merchant, not merchant, and
credit card verification,
error codes.
We've taken care of all
of that for you.
And what you get is a lot.
Support from us with
payment models.
All major browsers and platforms
are supported.
International currencies,
locales, all
taken care for you.
And you get the same security
and authentication that's
behind everything single Google
account on your site.
I think that's pretty cool.
So for more details, please
visit www.google.com/onepass.
You can sign up there as well.
And with that, we are going
to open up for Q and A.
Just a request, if you have a
question, please come up to
the mic, so that everybody
here can hear you.
And the video recording
captures you as well.
[INAUDIBLE]
OMI CHANDIRAMANI: Right, so
again that's all kind of taken
care of for you.
The billing address of the user
is what determines which
tax rate should be applied.
And that's Google Checkout
functionality.
So you don't have to worry about
which state is he from?
And again, there was no
code that did that.
All of that has been taken
care of for you.
I'm not sure the
mic is working?
But that previous question was
about sales taxes and how
they're applied.
Hi, so I had a question
about--
so I understand you have
different offers, like monthly
plans, subscriptions,
on so on.
So how do you categorize--
like if different parts
of my site are parts
of different offers--
Like do I have to upload
my inventory of
URLs or content sections?
How does that work?
OMI CHANDIRAMANI: Yeah,
I can take that.
When you set up an offer, you
do have to provide us with
some knowledge of the structure
of your site.
So if you have a--
it's example.com/news/star is
sold for a certain amount.
Then you create an offer and
you specify, OK, for this
offer, we include the content
under the /news/star.
Maybe another offer
has /sports/star.
Another offer could
have both of them.
So you can play with this.
$5 for news, $5 dollars for
sports, but $8 for both of
them together.
You can play with all of that.
So I can use Regexes or
something that define
different areas of my content.
OMI CHANDIRAMANI: That's right,
we allow Regexes and
they can get complicated.
Doesn't have to only begin with,
or end with, it can also
like contain.
It's Regex.
The power of Regex.
I had a question about--
You said giving access to
nondigital customers.
Or your print subscribers.
A lot of customers that I
integrate, they will have
their existing database of
users, and they want to check
and make sure they have a print
subscription before they
continue on.
Do you have a--
CHASE HANSEL: Yeah, so basically
if you want to do
authentication for some
existing print
subscriber or newspaper.
On that person's website, they
would set up a form, which
says, I think, what's the
standard these days?
Your phone number and
your address or
something like that.
So you type in that info, and
then basically, they would do
a check to their database.
And if the answer was yes, and
where they would essentially
use is one of those
discount coupons.
So then they would put a
discount coupon in the URL,
and they would get a new set of
offers, say free, or $1, or
you name it.
But basically it's a pretty
seamless system to the
consumer, where if they do
fulfilment and on the
publisher's website,
just get access.
This seems to be
very URL-based.
What happens if the URL of
the content changes?
Is there anything that helps
users pay for something and
it's at one location that
identifies the content,
independent of where it's
actually published?
So if it's moved around
the website, they
just don't get it?
Or is it tied to that particular
URL where they
originally accessed it?
OMI CHANDIRAMANI: Yeah,
you're right.
This is designed for sites to be
able to sell their content.
And the content is identified
by URL.
I do want to clarify
that, we take the
entire URL into account.
So if you have just one URL,
slash, article, dot CGI,
whatever, and the way you show
different content is by
passing different IDs
to that one URL.
We take that entire URL
into account with the
parameters as well.
So is that addressing
is your question?
Kind of.
I'm thinking of, let's say,
I'm covering something and
it's on the front page
of my site, and so
it's a content section.
But later, for whatever reason,
I decide to move it to
the archives.
I changed my publishing system
format, so the URL base
changes, I still old content
that's now being served
through the old system, but
it has a different URL.
OMI CHANDIRAMANI: Right.
So they're some tricks here.
You're right, if content moves
from one section of your site
to another, and the way you've
set up offers is based on
those sections, then
you're right.
Something that somebody had
bought in one offer is now in
another offer.
And there's some confusion
there.
But the power of this is in
how you define what the
content is.
So again, it comes back to
that regular expression
question, where if you can build
regular expressions to
consistently identify which
offer applies to what content,
then you're fine.
And really that's the only
way this can be done.
It's hard to track.
If you moved an article, and
there's no way even for you to
identify which offer it should
qualify for, then the system
can't either.
CHASE HANSEL: So more
concretely, you could have a
flash news and you could add
that your offer, and you could
also have /archive/news, and
they could both apply.
And if /archive/news had nothing
at the first point, it
doesn't really matter, right?
No one's going there.
That URL doesn't exist. But if
you can anticipate the fact
that it's going to move from
/news/ to /archive/news, then
you can just give the
user access to both.
And it just gets handled
behind the curtains.
Hi, there.
Saw your offer page.
Saw you said coupons, but I
didn't see anything in there
about metering.
And you had mentioned
on metering.
Could you expand on that?
CHASE HANSEL: So metering
works on the client.
So basically the way that we're
supporting metering is
no barrier to entry.
And the only real way to do
that is basically not have
anyone log in before they start
metering, but to use cookie.
So what you would expect is you
have a cookie that says
user has come once, user has
come twice, user has come
three times, great, showing
off our page.
And that's all client
side JavaScript.
So actually metering is
something that publishers are
doing with One Pass, but there's
actually no additional
set up on our end.
It's all client side
JavaScript.
So I've noticed that we passed
the encoded URL when the API
calls, and we're doing
the redirection
to everything else.
Do I have to give you the
same URL that the
page is actually on?
Or can I give you one that
means something to me?
OMI CHANDIRAMANI: You don't have
to give us the same URL,
just as long as you understand
what's going on.
That URL is where we're sending
the user back to.
And if that's where you
want the user to
end up, number one.
The other use of the URL was, if
that's the URL you want One
Pass to use to try and figure
out which offer to charge the
user for, that's fine.
We're not reading
the URL content.
It's just used to look up offers
and where to send the
user back to.
So it's both the regular
expression match and the
redirect that you're sending
the user back to.
OMI CHANDIRAMANI: OK, so the URL
that's in the param that
was passed in URL parameters,
the thing we escaped.
That's not the regular
expression URL, that's the
actual URL.
No, I know but it's used to
match against the regular
expressions that you
reconfigured.
As well as so you'd be
redirecting the user back.
And you're OK if I put in
something different there, so
long as I understand
what's going on.
OMI CHANDIRAMANI: Yeah,
it's your site.
And you own the user experience
if that's what
makes sense in your context.
Perfect, thank you.
A couple of questions,
actually.
A lot the questions have been
centered around publishers for
magazines or something.
Is that a restriction
right now?
Policy restriction?
Or can it be like a service
or log into some--
OMI CHANDIRAMANI: Content
publisher.
We use that term very broadly.
We're not trying to restrict
it to anybody.
That's just the best word that
we could come up with that
captures anybody that puts
content on the web.
This actually is--
the other question I had is
this actually has a lot of
implications as far as non-web
based stuff as well.
Like I want to create trial
software, I guess it was asked
previously already, but
it's still tied to the
concept of a URL?
CHASE HANSEL: Yes, it's tied
to the concept of URL.
OMI CHANDIRAMANI: Yes, it is.
Hi, I'm from Hong Kong.
I'm working for a magazine
publishing company.
And we are considering
making Android
magazine in coming months.
We are excited about One Pass,
but we have a question.
When will it come to Asia?
CHASE HANSEL: So One Pass is
currently available in the US,
Canada, France, Italy, Spain,
Germany, and the UK.
We are, ideally by the end of
the month, going to be able to
support merchants in all
Checkout merchants countries,
which includes Hong Kong.
Which should be end of May.
I don't know.
These things tend to slip.
So I would say probably
realistically, June.
But it's something we're
actively working on.
Great, thanks.
I have a question.
Is the token visible
to the consumer?
And is that open?
Like if they share that URL with
a token, what protects
that URL from other
people taking
advantage of the content?
OMI CHANDIRAMANI: Right.
So one of the qualities of the
token that I didn't mention in
my slide, is that it expires
very quickly.
Within minutes, actually.
So you can't buy something, send
the URL to somebody else,
and have them be able to
access the content.
Think of it as a cached version
of the access check
that expires in two minutes.
That's the action number.
Two questions.
What are the fees for
this, first of all?
CHASE HANSEL: 10%.
Google takes 10%.
OK, and do you process
microtransactions, like even sub-cent?
CHASE HANSEL: There's
no minimum.
So you can take sub-cent
things like--
CHASE HANSEL: I do believe
it's a cent.
I would have to check with
the Checkout folks.
Do you take 10% of a cent?
CHASE HANSEL: For example,
that example I
gave was EUR 0.10.
[INAUDIBLE]
CHASE HANSEL: Yeah,
so this is 10%.
No minimums, credit card.
[INAUDIBLE]
CHASE HANSEL: So the use of this
is up to the policy of
the device.
Technically, yes.
You would have to run it by
the policy of each market.
[INAUDIBLE]
CHASE HANSEL: How would you
do it with web use?
Yes.
OMI CHANDIRAMANI: If you have a
browser environment that can
support your implementation,
then it would work.
There's nothing here that was
specific to any environment,
even the JavaScript that
we showed you.
All of that logic could be
on the server side if
that's what you want.
So it's a pretty flexible
system.
You can do a lot with it in
multiple environments.
All right Thanks for
coming, guys.